doom was a pleasant and ferocious
surprise to us all expectations were
tempted due to its rocky and uncertain
development cycle and flat multiplayer
beta but all that went out of the window
when you were thrust into the wild
rollercoaster ride that was doomed
single-player campaign it's fast frantic
and smooth as hell every weapon packs a
punch
and every demon is vicious it reveled in
the simplicity of classic run and gun
gameplay but added modern touches like
weapon modifications and upgrade paths
for abilities glory kills for health and
chainsaw kills for ammo added a
strategic layer to combat Doom succeeded
because it went all in on the overtop
self-aware attitude its core mechanics
were executed with precision and the
game rewarded exploration within its
atmospheric world civilization is one of
gaming's marquee strategy franchises and
PC gamers were granted another amazing
entry into the series civics retains its
underlying Forex strategy formula but
enriches its mechanics and systems
unstack cities made turn-by-turn
planning more nuanced diplomacy was
better implemented and could be used to
exchange luxury goods to keep citizens
happy and established trade routes to
enrich everyone involved if you couldn't
talk to yourself well you can consider
us friend the civics research tree which
now runs parallel to the technologies
tree added deeper options for players
seeking cultural victories all these
tweaks refine the strategy experience
which already had a strong foundation
it's arguably the most complete base
civilization game to date
[Music]
while other shooters went to the future
this year battlefield one returned to an
era of the past albeit a dark and grim
the detailed ambient sound design paired
with the explosions and gunfire capture
a gruesome atmosphere that complements
its bleak beautifully destructive
environments and jaw-dropping visual
fidelity the single-player campaign
handled the weight of World War one with
respect each vignette that portrayed the
Great War gave players inside to its
mentality scale and effect on human
lives but battlefields draw has been and
always will be large-scale multiplayer
and battlefield one's operations mode is
a definite highlight with historically
grounded maps buried ground in air
combat and improved progression systems
players have several reasons to come
back instead of defending Earth from an
alien invasion
XCOM to twist the narrative humankind is
fighting for survival after being
occupied by the aliens theme of
desperation is set from the start
XCOM to test players and made them
rethink what it means to play a strategy
game it's a symmetric style of battles
fit the feel of guerrilla warfare you're
forced to think steps ahead become
resourceful and be prepared to retreat
you can't win every fight and players
have to deal with the consequences of
failure you'll lose soldiers lose
territories but how you learn from
failure makes X come to a truly unique
experience it's all wrapped into a
cohesive fun and rewarding package that
is an outstanding addition to one of
PC's most acclaimed franchises overwatch
revolutionize class-based team shooters
each character was crafted with
tremendous thought and detail not only
in their aesthetic but in their in-game
abilities as well the game is designed
to encourage teamwork and thoughtful
team composition and it eases players
into these elements in the most helpful
way possible from on-screen prompts to
easily recognizable character animations
and sound design players always know
what's happening but it's up to players
to think critically and band together to
push for victory it's easy to learn hard
to master
Blizzard also spawned a cultural
phenomenon the animated shorts gave
characters deeper backstory and
overwatch cosplay is taking over
conventions it's another stunning
example of how Blizzard precisely crafts
its games whether you like overwatch or
not there's no denying it caused a
paradigm shift and multiplayer game
[Music]